for example the Google News experience
on the desktop shows a lot of
information but the mobile experience
focuses on just the news stories pushing
all the secondary information out of the
way
you'll learn how to write code that
adapts to different screen sizes and
also how to make your code work offline
you'll learn how pointer input works on
touch screens and how to unlock the
camera GPS and accelerometer sensors on
mobile devices now technically speaking
you don't need a mobile device in order
to take this course or even to test out
most of what you'll learn but you're
missing a lot of the experience of
mobile web development without a device
preferably at least one Android device
you can use Chrome's great mobile
debugging tools which we'll be using in
this course but the more devices you
have and the more variety the better